from their base camp at kushi
25 kilometers northwest of saigon
elements of the 25th infantry division
set out on another search and destroy
mission
this sweep on november 3rd is part of
operation kalihi
which began in early september
from hobo woods to the northern reaches
of war zone
c these airborne strikes against the
vietcong
are an old story to the men of the
tropic lightning division
all strikes are similar yet each
operation
is different
landing in some jungle meadow where the
enemy may be watching and waiting
is always an anxious affair for the men
of the first wave
the immediate job is to secure the
landing zone
and they move quickly to the perimeter
of the field
within minutes the second wave of troops
arrives
and the mission to search the field hole
rubber plantation
is about to get underway
on the perimeter of the landing zone the
company commander radios an armored
column
which will rendezvous with the troops
some distance away the apc's respond
then it's time to move out and the
troopers of the red tarot leaf enter the
jungle
which borders the huge rubber plantation
again and again
the enemy has been reported in this area
one of the toughest vietcong strongholds
in vietnam
600 meters from the landing zone the
infantrymen are joined by seven
armored personnel carriers during the
night which followed
these units were hit by the vietcong
with mortars and rifle grenades
our return fire continues well into
daylight
by 0 800 hours the men of the 25th are
closing in on the cluster of buildings
which once housed the plantation offices
and work sheds the shelling from the
apc's and our mortars
has reduced the structures to rubble
the viet cong have withdrawn taking
their casualties with them
the searchers press onward toward the
village of phu hua dong
where they will serve as a blocking
force for vietnamese rangers of the
fifth arvin division
sweeping down from the northeast
through the tangle of vines and clinging
jungle growth
the apc's cut a swath where the
advancing troops can follow
emerging from the dense jungle
surrounding the rubber plantation
the troopers find the vietcong have
scattered
here a meeting is held to coordinate
forces before entering the village the
plan is discussed
with the american advisor to the urban
units
the viet cong stronghold appears
deserted
as the tropic lightning troops
cautiously begin their probe
with the arvind forces covering all
avenues of escape to the north and east
the americans search from house to house
the unnatural silence is oppressive and
tension mounts
one of the searchers has triggered a
viet cong booby trap
he is badly wounded and must be
evacuated immediately
a howitzer shell was rigged as the booby
trap
if it's ready bring the man back up here
so that we can pull the copper in
the mission goes on this is what it's
like
during operation kalihi
an urgent request for artillery support
is called in from a reconnaissance
platoon
hit by viet cong grenades and rifle fire
the response of the howitzer battery is
immediate and their 105 millimeter guns
open up
it is 18 november and operation
attleboro
the largest scale operation in the war
to date is in its fourth week
its objective to destroy war zone sea as
a vietcong sanctuary
brigadier general john r dean assistant
commander of the first infantry division
is briefed on the engagement the 28-man
patrol was hit
while moving through a wooded area 30
kilometers northwest of tainine
as the patrol moves clear of the area an
air strike is called in
the strain of concern and fatigue is
etched on many faces
as the strike is directed onto enemy
positions threatening the patrol
first infantry division commander major
general william d pew
arrives to discuss the situation with
major general fred wyant
commander of the 25th infantry division
attleboro involves elements of several
divisions
with a big red one in operational
control
uh-1d air ambulances begin to arrive
with the first of the wounded from the
ambush patrol
some men have been hit pretty hard and
are being landed at the command post for
emergency treatment
before going on to hospital general de
pew personally presents
several purple hearts right on the spot
the wounds are bandaged
and splints fixed in place as quickly as
possible
then the wounded are put back aboard the
choppers and evacuation continues
a call from the patrol leader is
received confirming that the bombardment
and airstrike has driven off the enemy
the platoon cautiously returns to sweep
the area
and a cache of enemy weapons is
discovered they are examined by general
dean
and brigadier general charles
hollingsworth also
assistant division commander of the
first infantry
the captured equipment includes
ammunition grenades
several types of mines rifles and a
shotgun
as well as a number of vietcong maps
operation attleboro which has already
claimed a thousand enemy dead
and three million pounds of captured
rice continues successfully
air boat operation in vietnam begins in
the classroom
where skilled instructors using enlarged
mock-ups of controls
teach vietnamese army personnel and
mercenaries
fundamentals an engine is checked out by
an instructor
prior to a trial run then the boats line
up for the start
a machine gunner gives his weapon a last
minute check
the fiberglass propeller driven boats
are powered by 180 horsepower
engines in these scenes photographed at
kanto
and kai kai on 15 and 16 november
trial runs across reed-filled marshes
give the new crews experience in
maneuvering
the instructor teaches the operators to
cross low obstacles in the water
gunners learn to scan the growth for any
signs of the viet cong hidden along
their route
maneuvering in narrow canals is
practiced
trainees learn to pass each other in the
limited space
but occasionally one is hung up
but they are soon disengaged and off
again
precise beaching techniques are taught
using markers the instructor is exacting
with the trainees
the boats continue beaching practice
under the instructor's critical eye
and when they're right it's thumbs up
a young crew member enjoys recognition
of his friends on shore
as the boat moves rapidly past the
village
soon the boat teams are out on actual
patrol
their normal crew augmented by three
civilian irregular defense personnel
the boats are now operational in four
sections of the fourth core
area the vietcong
have a great fear of these boats which
they refer to
as jeep boats the soldiers stop at a
civilian hut
to ask if the vietcong have been in the
area
fast and efficient these boats greatly
increase the effectiveness of water
patrol teams
at dawn on 9 november in vietnam
an escorted convoy prepares to leave
natron
weapons are checked as the road to ban
metoot may be
intercepted by the viet cong
tankers carrying vital fuel are
protected against possible attack by the
enemy
members of the 272nd mp company of
natron
remain on the alert as the convoy
proceeds along the road
the convoy arrives safely at van metoot
and stands by to refuel the depot
the fighting men of the first brigade
101st airborne division
form up to pay tribute to a comrade on
the 28th day of october
here at tuihua first sergeant walter
sabalewski is retiring after 30 years of
service
general william c westmoreland u.s
commander in vietnam
and brigadier general willard pearson
commanding the first brigade
troop the line
these ceremonies not only mark the end
of a gallant soldier's career spanning
three wars
but honor him for repeated acts of
bravery while engaged in a two-day
battle with the viet cong on june 9 and
10.
during the battle at ducktalk khan
valley first sergeant sabalewski
was wounded but refused evacuation
fighting on until the enemy was repelled
now he is awarded the distinguished
service cross by general westmoreland
for first sergeant walter sobalewski a
fitting climax to the veterans years of
service
patrol boats of the u.s navy move up the
joe dock river
to search for people stranded in
vietnam's worst flood in years
the entire mekong delta land is affected
in the region 190 kilometers southwest
of saigon
villages and farms are completely
inundated as the mekong river and its
tributaries
overflow their banks fed by heavy rains
of the monsoon season
the rivers flood these lowlands every
year but 1966
is the worst on record
every bit of high ground such as
nuisance mountain
is occupied by refugees during the first
week of october
at nuisance members of the u.s army
special forces
have set up a refugee relief camp and
daily distribute food and administer
medical aid
similar camps have been established in
other localities
long accustomed to a life of privation
and hard labor
these vietnamese peasants accept the new
burden
imposed by nature with calm resignation
when the floods recede they will resume
their work in the rice fields
for those who live and work in the towns
like ciao dock
the flood is an even greater disaster
shops and merchandise
businesses and homes all are ruined
communications are disrupted and food is
in short supply
excluding the loss of the rice harvest
damage is estimated in the millions
in a joint effort to assist the flood
victims the u.s army special forces
the u.s navy and the united states
agency for international development
are cooperating in the relief program
a mobile navy medical unit administers
typhus serum with a lightning fast
high-pressure air injector
with the crisis now under control
vietnam looks toward a rapid recovery
from the flood of 1966.
thanksgiving in vietnam takes many forms
at the fifth special forces camp near
benoit the traditional turkey is ready
for a rather untraditional journey
prepared by sergeant lonnie mitchell the
bird is destined for a special forces
detachment
dug in at zomcott in war zone d and
accessible only by air
after being carved and packed in marmite
cans
the turkey and trimmings are ready to go
since the bird can't do any more flying
of its own
a chopper does the honors
after being landed at an lz near the
12-man unit
the eagerly awaited feast is trucked
over the last leg of the journey
on reaching the detachment the sergeant
sets up his chow line as quickly as
possible
the men are expecting an attack by a
north vietnamese unit
but even that grim prospect doesn't dim
their enjoyment
thanksgiving dinner with cranberry sauce
sweet potatoes and pumpkin pie
still tastes mighty good
similar airlift operations to many
isolated units
were typical of this year's thanksgiving
in vietnam
near melgar at the colombian army's
engineer maintenance and supply company
a u.s mobile training team from the
canal zone
begins maintenance classes for a group
of soldier mechanics the company
supported by the u.s military aid
program is almost entirely concerned
with road building projects throughout
the nation
for colombia which is divided into three
parts by the andes
modern roads are vital to development
many of the classes are held outdoors
and stress
practical experience with the more than
600 pieces of equipment in use by the
outfit
when the americans leave some of the nco
students will take over as instructors
for incoming recruits
in a related project another u.s team
has been assigned to the colombian
mechanized reconnaissance battalion
in bogota the colombian unit possessed a
wide range of map supplied equipment
but there were few operators qualified
to use it
the u.s team set up a four-week course
for officers and ncos
covering theory engineering maintenance
and
plenty of practice
several days are spent on each type of
radio and the progress of each student
carefully graded
sergeant elio fregoso instructs the
group in the use of the a
n slash or109 portable radio with hand
cranked power supply
graduation is held at the completion of
the course each man receives
congratulations
and a diploma certifying him as a
qualified operator
the seventh army aviation training
center at schleicheim
10 miles north of munich has been
organized by a directive of the
department of the army
based on its worldwide requirements for
additional helicopter pilots
the mission of this center is to qualify
250 user or fixed wing
aviators as rotary wing aviators
prior to 31 december 1966
the intensive course includes 136 hours
of academic instruction
including aerodynamics helicopter
maintenance
tactics and flight line subjects
military instructors are aided by field
service representatives
such as mr bill owens of bell helicopter
corporation
who explains the system of the rotor
blade assembly
145 hours are devoted to flying time
the aviators learn to pilot the oh 13
with transition training in the uh-1b
and ch-34
takeoff landing and aircraft maneuvering
have been integrated into the course
advanced students are trained to airlift
sling loads
guided by a signal man the student pilot
comes in
for a clean hookup
clearly the seventh army aviation school
is taking up the slack
in the training of helicopter pilots
the 32nd army air defense command with
its nike hercules and mobile hawk
missile battalions serves to protect
europe's skies against enemy aggression
to ensure maximum operational readiness
among hawk missile batteries operational
readiness evaluation teams visit the
sites
for spot checks upon their arrival
part of the team checks in at the
battery control center
the operator is informed that an o-r-e
is about to begin
to simulate battle stations the
evaluator announces blazing skies
and starts to clock the fire unit the
alert is sounded
and the crew emerges from the ready room
on the double
on a dead run they head for their
assigned posts
they must be ready to fire in 15 minutes
communications are established with a
control center
while a crew prepares the missiles
the evaluator carefully observes the
checks being made
to ensure that they are being properly
performed
at the radars another ore evaluator
observes the crew as they apply power
and make adjustments
the system is on the air another
readiness evaluation has been made by
ore
at the luxembourg american military
cemetery on 11
november a ceremony is held in honor of
general george patton
who led the troops liberating luxembourg
the formalities are part of the
armistice day celebration
held near luxembourg city
general edward a bailey assistant
division commander eighth infantry
division
addresses the guests then members of
girl scout and boy scout organizations
carry wreaths from the monument down the
chapel steps
to be placed on the gravesites
among the graves honored is that of
general patton
the ceremony reflects the inscription on
the monument
proud remembrance
you